This video that I'm going to play for you
is hilarious.
Yesterday I reported to you the latest Fox
news poll Fox, which says, 54% of the country
wants Trump impeached.
50% wants Trump impeached and removed.
The team over at Fox and friends had some
cognitive dissonance on this one.
On the one hand, they work for Fox news.
They think Fox news is right about the facts,
but they also can't believe that anybody but
the most extreme leftists would want Donald
Trump impeached.
So here is video of Fox news host Brian Kilmeade
visibly stunned by the results.
On the one hand, it's a Fox news poll.
We believe Fox news polls, but the Fox news
poll says half the country wants Trump impeached
and removed.
How could it be if you're watching?
You may notice a perplexed look on Steve Doocy
and Ainslie Earhart's faces as well.
Take a look at this.
Fox poll came out and I was stunned by this.
This is 50% of the country want the president
impeached.
I was stunned to see that that's the number
because I thought they'd be things that were
trending away.
Uh, although the president's approval rating
did take up in the same poll, so it's almost
like a split personality.
How could this be?
Say it ain't so, this is what it looks like
when reality simply doesn't fit into the Fox
narrative.
And again, I said this yesterday and I want
to say it again.
Different news outlets are playing coy with
the momentum saying, wow, during impeachment
hearings, support for impeachment went down.
Usually it's like by two or three points.
These polls have a margin of error of plus
or minus three.
So a three point swing arguably means nothing,
and the poll is nowhere near 50% on lots of
important internals.
If you look at the same Fox news poll, you
see that by a 60 to 24 margin, it is wrong
to ask leaders of foreign countries to investigate
rivals.
That's not close.
That's 60 to 24 58 to 22 Americans say presidents
typically ask foreign leaders to do this.
It should be 100 versus zero.
Since clearly it's not common.
Trump supporters can't seem to admit that
and are trying to use that as a defense.
52 to 36 saying Trump isn't cooperating with
the inquiry.
That's very clear.
People understand Trump is not cooperating
here, but once again, the most important thing
to remember is that these numbers include
Republicans who said in a recent poll that
Trump is a better president than Abraham Lincoln.
We should actually be shocked that only merely
50% want Trump impeached and removed.
But then you think back and realize, Oh, half
of Republicans think Trump is a better president
than Lincoln.
Nearly two thirds of Republicans say they
would never abandon Donald Trump, no matter
what he does, then we should actually recognize
the significance of merely hitting 50% support
for impeachment.
Despite all of those people that are completely
disconnected from the facts and defend Trump
no matter what to the death.
So sometimes the bubble of alternative facts
is so thick that people forget.
There's a reality out there.
Your narrative isn't real.
That's what Brian Kilmeade seems to be smacked
in the face with directly in this video.
But if it's real enough to the people watching
Fox news, it's real enough to do serious damage
to the country's ability to think critically.
And that's where we find ourselves today.
Because really imagine being stunned that
half the country wants the man who is arguably
the most corrupt president in the modern presidential
era removed from office for his corruption
that shouldn't be stunning.
And yet somehow Brian Kilmeade is stunned
by that very backwards situation that we are
in.